what up YouTube super excited for this
unique video episode this is the biz dev
barter of empathy Wine episode the last
48 72 hours has been remarkable I
haven't bartered my time in a long time
my number one goal in life is to not
have to ever barter the thing that I
value the most which is my time access
to me however once in a while you have a
big project empathy whines maybe d-roc
you can uh you can edit and like
superimpose it right here but on my
birthday a couple weeks ago I announced
empathy whines calm my winery the best
$40 wine made for 20 bucks is kind of
how I thought about it red white and
rose a and over the last 72 hours John
Troutman and Nate and Nora and the team
at empathy wines have been doing the
barter thing and it's been remarkable
and its really going well and then I
realized huh I haven't told everybody
about it and so I'm like huh I haven't
done anything for YouTube about this
let's do the right thing by YouTube a
because I want to make sure they get the
a bats B because I have five or six more
packages in me so go to the URL that's
popped up right now go to that URL
submit your offer in a world where I get
10,000 emails a month I was like how do
I get 30 minutes with you or how do I
get a five-minute FaceTime or how do I
get a full day or how could I shadow the
team we are available for a couple more
hours before I feel good about how much
wine has been sold which is getting very
close and so YouTube you get two last
at-bat at the barter offers for empathy
wines make sure you read the information
I'm not giving you ten minutes of my
time for three cases this is this is big
girl big boy stuff so for all the people
out there that are ready to take the
next step in their business or their
life and feel like there's a worthwhile
trade and they can take the wine and
donate it or use it as corporate gifts
or drink it you know this is definitely
more in the 50 60 70 80 200 case game
real bucks but you'll get all the
details on the URL link in the
information here Gary B team please put
the URL in the comments and pin it d-roc
edit like a son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] have
the best day ever YouTube thank you so
much for watching my content appreciate
this right hook but hopefully you get
the right hook back
I think the reason you can tell my
Energy's awesome is I love one plus one
equals three right I get to sell fifty
two hundred three hundred cases when I
need to because this is a big project I
want to get out there and people are
getting something they can't get which
is me or a free ticket to four DS in
theory because they were debating it
anyway you'll see you'll see on the page
thank you
you
[Music]